When Aaryn was nine, her family moved from China to Canada. And there was this pool in their apartment complex. And one day her dad was like, let's try out the pool. And Aaryn's super excited and her dad is meanwhile thinking, she doesn't know how to swim. Time to fix that.
当Aaryn九岁时，全家从中国搬到了加拿大。他们公寓大楼里有个游泳池。有一天她爸爸说，去泳池试试吧。Aaryn非常兴奋，而她爸爸心里却在想，她还不会游泳，是时候解决这个问题了。
And as soon as they get to the pool he picks her up, throws her in the deep end.
他们一到泳池边，他抱起她就扔进了深水区。
And I start screaming. And I still didn't really know what was going on. And I was screaming and struggling in the water. And every few seconds I can kind of see above water my dad standing there like looking at me. And I'm screaming and he's not really reacting.
我开始尖叫。当时我还真不知道发生了什么。我在水里尖叫挣扎，每隔几秒钟，我能从水面上方看到爸爸站在那里看着我。我在尖叫，而他却没什么反应。
And then I see like the other kids and their parents. And they were looking really disapproving.
然后我看到了其他孩子和他们的父母。他们看起来非常不赞同。
Did you feel, like at the moment that he threw you in, did you feel betrayed by him?
在你被扔进去的那一刻，你有感到被他背叛了吗？
I felt angry. I felt angry that I was embarrassed because of something he did.
我感到愤怒。我感到愤怒是因为他的所作所为让我感到尴尬。
Did you feel angry that you might drown? I mean, aren't you leaving out that? I like that the embarrassment is a bigger thing in your head at that moment than like oh, I might actually just die right now.
你有没有因为可能会淹死而感到愤怒？我是说，你是不是忽略了这一点？我倒觉得，那一刻你脑子里尴尬比“天哪，我现在可能会死”更重要。
I really didn't think I would. Like that didn't even crossed my mind. Like what I was thinking the most was oh, my god. All these white kids and their parents are watching me. Like I was trying to will myself into learning how to swim so I wouldn't have to keep embarrassing myself.
我真的没觉得我会死。这念头根本没在我脑子里出现过。我当时想得最多的是，天哪，所有这些白人小孩和他们的父母都在看着我。我当时在拼命想办法学会游泳，这样我就不用再丢脸了。
It is literally only now, only once she started talking about this for our radio show that the thought occurred to her that maybe all those people weren't looking disapprovingly at her, but at her dad. Back when she was nine she just blamed herself for failing.
直到现在，直到她开始为我们的广播节目谈论这件事，她才意识到，也许那些人看着的不是她，而是她爸爸。九岁时，她只是因为自己做不到而自责。
I remember thinking like how could you not know how to swim? You just have to swim and be OK. Look at all these people staring at you. And look at the look on your dad's face. Just swim.
我记得当时在想，你怎么连游泳都不会？你只要游起来就没事了。看看所有这些人都在盯着你。看看你爸爸脸上的表情。快游啊。
And then I feel myself sinking and I can only see water around me. And then a few seconds later, I don't know how long, I feel someone grab me. And then I see that it's my dad. And we slowly get out of the pool. And he didn't really talk to me for the rest of the night.
然后我感觉到自己在下沉，周围只有水。几秒钟后，我不知道过了多久，我感觉到有人抓住了我。然后我看到是我爸爸。我们慢慢地走出了泳池。那天晚上剩下的时间里他都没跟我说话。
She did overhear him telling her mom, I don't know what's wrong, it should have been easy. She should've been able to do it. In the years since, she has never talked to him about it.
她确实无意中听到他跟她妈妈说，不知道怎么回事，这应该很容易的。她本该能做到的。从那以后的几年里，她从未和他谈起过这件事。
But this whole idea of sink or swim, I mean, the actual sink or swim-- you know, throw a kid into the deep end of the pool-- it seems so contrary to all of the other nicey, nicey ways that we try to teach kids about everything else. And it is way more common than you think. It happened to two of our producers here on the show, Emmanuel and Matt. It happened to my wife. They were just tossed in over their heads, no warning, totally caught off guard.
但这种“沉还是游”的理念，也就是真正的“沉还是游”——你知道，把孩子扔进深水区——这似乎与我们试图教孩子其他事情的所有那些温和、委婉的方式背道而驰。而且这比你想象的要普遍得多。我们节目的两位制作人Emmanuel和Matt都经历过，我妻子也经历过。他们都是在毫无防备的情况下，突然被扔进了深水里。
Aaryn says it didn't traumatize her. In fact, it motivated her to try to teach herself to swim a month later so there'd be no further embarrassment.
Aaryn说这并没有给她留下心理创伤。事实上，这激励她在一个月后尝试自学游泳，这样就不会再尴尬了。
You know what's the weird part of this strategy is the element of surprise.
你知道这个策略最奇怪的地方就是突袭的成分。
Yeah.
是啊。
Like it seems like if you're going to do this with your kid you could say, here's what we're going to do. I'm going to throw you in the pool and you're going to swim your way out. Like the thought that he would surprise you, it just seems like a completely unnecessary extra bonus piece of trauma to throw on the whole thing.
感觉如果你要和孩子这样做的话，你可以说，我们要这样做。我要把你扔进泳池，你要自己游出来。他那种突袭你的想法，似乎完全没必要，只是给整件事额外增加了一点心理创伤。
Yeah, I don't know why he chose to do that. I should ask him some time.
是啊，我不知道他为什么选择那样做。我哪天应该问问他。
Can we call him?
我们可以打给他吗？
[PHONE BEEPING]
[电话嘟嘟声]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Mama.
妈妈。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
This, of course, is the universal sound of one parent getting the other parent on the phone. Once her dad was on the line, Aaryn explained why we were calling.
这当然是全世界通用的父母给另一方打电话的声音。Aaryn的爸爸接通电话后，Aaryn解释了我们为什么要打这个电话。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Deep end.
[非英语语音] 深水区。
And I have to say, this must have been a very strange call for Aaryn's dad to get at 10:00 at night in China. His daughter lives in Europe these days, plus some man from a radio show in America he's never heard of asking about a totally random incident that happened in Canada 16 years ago.
我不得不说，对于身在中国、晚上十点接到这个电话的Aaryn的爸爸来说，这一定非常奇怪。他的女儿如今住在欧洲，还有一个他从未听说过的美国广播节目的男人，问起16年前在加拿大发生的一件完全随机的琐事。
I cannot exactly remember that. That's really a long time ago. I cannot remember it.
我不记得具体情况了。那是很久以前的事了。我不记得了。
The phone line is bad. He's saying I cannot exactly remember that. That's really a long time ago. I cannot remember it. Aaryn's dad said that being thrown into the deep end of the pool was not like some traditional way they taught swimming back home in the village he came from. He didn't learn that way.
电话线路不好。他说我不记得具体情况了。那是很久以前的事了。我不记得了。Aaryn的爸爸说，被扔进深水区并不是他们老家那种教游泳的传统方式。他自己也不是那样学的。
And yet when I asked him would he teach a child today to swim that way, would he throw her into the deep end of the pool? He said yeah, maybe.
然而，当我问他今天是否还会用那种方式教孩子游泳，是否会把她扔进深水区时，他说，也许吧。
Maybe. I think maybe.
也许。我觉得也许吧。
Maybe.
也许。
So you don't think it's a bad idea?
所以你不觉得这是个坏主意？
No, I don't think so. No.
不，我不这么认为。不。
Aaryn was unsurprised. When he got off the phone she told me even when she was nine and flailing around in the water, for him to throw her in like that, it wasn't like she was seeing some insane side of him she'd never seen before, some unheard of behavior.
Aaryn并不感到惊讶。当她挂断电话后，她告诉我，即使在她九岁时在水里乱扑腾的时候，他那样把她扔进去，对她来说也并不像是看到了他从未展现过的疯狂一面，或者什么闻所未闻的行为。
No, that's not insane for my dad. Like it seemed really on character for him to do that. Like if it had been anything else, driving a car.
不，对我爸爸来说这并不疯狂。这对他来说真的很符合他的性格。如果是其他事情的话，比如开车。
Like with roller blades he just dropped me off at a grocery store parking lot, made me put them on myself, and then gave me a shopping cart and said hold on to this and you'll learn. And then he drove away and said come home when you're tired. It's just how he thinks I'll learn best, I guess.
就像轮滑，他只是把我扔在杂货店的停车场，让我自己穿上，然后给了我一个购物车，说抓紧它，你就会学会了。然后他就开车走了，说累了就回家。我想这就是他认为我能学得最好的方式吧。
This is a whole coherent strategy for life. It's tough out there. Stuff's gotta get done. Coddling ourselves, coddling others, that's not going to do anybody any good. Today on our program we have two very different stories in which people are thrown into the deep end of the pool, asked to do things they were totally inexperienced at and unprepared for in situations with very high stakes.
这是一种完整的人生策略。外面的世界很艰难。事情必须完成。溺爱自己，溺爱别人，对谁都没有好处。今天我们的节目有两个非常不同的故事，人们都被扔进了深水区，被要求去做他们完全没有经验、没有准备的事，处境非常高风险。
In one story, a man faces 20 years in prison. And in the other, the United States faces an implacable foe on a quest for global domination. I am not kidding, global domination. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
在一个故事中，一名男子面临20年监禁。在另一个故事中，美国面临着一个为了全球统治而不懈追求的敌人。我没开玩笑，全球统治。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act One, If You Cannot Afford an Attorney, Some Random Dude Will Be Appointed to You.
第一幕，如果你请不起律师，会有一个随机分配的家伙。
So one of the many, many things that we all know from watching television is that when you get arrested, someone is supposed to read you your Miranda rights. And those rights include the right to an attorney. And if you cannot afford an attorney, one will be given to you for free.
我们从电视节目中都知道的一件事是，当你被捕时，有人应该宣读你的米兰达权利。这些权利包括聘请律师的权利。如果你请不起律师，政府会免费为你提供一名律师。
Well, those free attorneys, public defenders, they have never been adequately funded in lots of states. And in recent years, the problem has reached crisis levels. Lots of public defenders offices around the country simply do not have the money and staff to provide a lawyer to everyone who needs one. And in some states, Florida, Tennessee, Missouri, Montana, Louisiana, the court just picks random lawyers and makes them take the cases.
好吧，那些免费律师，即公设辩护人，在许多州从未获得足够的资助。近年来，这个问题已经达到了危机水平。全国各地的许多公设辩护人办公室根本没有足够的资金和人员为每个需要的人提供律师。在一些州，如佛罗里达州、田纳西州、密苏里州、蒙大拿州、路易斯安那州，法院只是随机挑选律师，并强迫他们接手这些案件。
A few weeks ago you might have seen this in the news, the public defender's office in Missouri tried to assign a case like this, it was an assault case, to the governor of Missouri, Jay Nixon, who's a member of the bar. The head of the public defender's office said it was appropriate to give the case to him because quote, "he was the one attorney in the state who not only created this problem, but is in a unique position to address it" by giving them more funding.
几周前你可能在新闻中看到过，密苏里州的公设辩护人办公室试图将一个案件，这是一个袭击案，分配给密苏里州州长Jay Nixon，他也是律师协会的成员。公设辩护人办公室负责人说，把案件交给他很合适，因为“他是州里唯一不仅制造了这个问题，而且处于独特位置来解决它的人”，即给他们更多资助。
The governor, apparently, is not going to take that case. But other lawyers have to. And there's an interesting problem when they assign these random lawyers to these cases. Often, these attorneys have no experience at all in the kind of law they're going to have to use in the cases.
州长显然不会接那个案子。但其他律师必须接。当他们将这些随机律师分配到这些案件时，出现了一个有趣的问题。通常，这些律师在他们必须处理的案件类型上完全没有经验。
So for example, if you're picked up for marijuana possession, your fate might be in the hands of a lawyer who specializes in real estate. Reporter David Zax has a story of a case like that in Louisiana, Shreveport, which is in Caddo Parish.
例如，如果你因为持有大麻被捕，你的命运可能掌握在一个专门从事房地产工作的律师手中。记者David Zax有关于路易斯安那州什里夫波特（卡多教区）此类案件的故事。
The case went to a guy who is not prepared for it. Quick warning to listeners, there is no explicit or graphic content in this story at all, but there is some colorful cursing. That's actually true for both acts of today's program. And if you prefer a show that has been beeped, maybe you listen with kids in the car, you can get that at our website thisamericanlife.org. OK, here's David.
案件交给了一个对此毫无准备的家伙。提醒听众，这个故事中没有任何露骨或血腥的内容，但有一些粗鲁的咒骂。今天节目的两个部分其实都是如此。如果你喜欢经过消音处理的节目，或者如果你和孩子们一起在车里听，你可以在我们的网站thisamericanlife.org上找到。好了，听听David的讲述。
This case is about a burglary. One night a few years ago, a woman woke up to a flashlight shining in her face. This was in Shreveport, Louisiana, in the northwest corner of the state.
这个案件是关于入室盗窃的。几年前的一个晚上，一位女士醒来时发现手电筒照在她的脸上。这发生在路易斯安那州什里夫波特市，该州的西北角。
The woman screamed and the burglars fled. They made off with two TVs, a computer, an iPhone. But they'd also left some evidence behind, a cigarette butt, a crowbar, and a hat, a black baseball cap.
女士尖叫起来，盗贼逃跑了。他们偷走了两台电视、一台电脑、一部iPhone。但他们也留下了一些证据，一个烟蒂、一根撬棍和一顶帽子，一顶黑色棒球帽。
The police bagged the hat and they sent it to the crime lab for DNA testing. It turned out that some DNA in the hat matched a man named Trastavien Hardy. A warrant was issued for his arrest and he turned himself in. Shreveport was one of those places assigning private attorneys to cases like this because they don't have enough public defenders.
警方把帽子装进证物袋，送往犯罪实验室进行DNA检测。结果发现，帽子上的DNA与一名叫Trastavien Hardy的男子相符。针对他的逮捕令发布了，他自首了。什里夫波特就是那些将此类案件分配给私人律师的地方，因为他们没有足够的公设辩护人。
So the judge, he looked at this list he had of private attorneys in the area. It was alphabetical, and he just picked the next name. Jack Bailey, one of those accident and injury guys whose ads you see all over the place.
所以法官看着他手里的当地私人律师名单。那是按字母顺序排列的，他选了下一个名字。Jack Bailey，那些你在到处都能看到广告的事故和伤害律师之一。
I hope you work every day without being hurt on the job, drive without someone running a stop sign, go through life without ever being hurt because of someone else's stupidity.
我希望你每天工作都不会受伤，开车时不会有人闯红灯，一生中都不会因为别人的愚蠢而受伤。
This one is beautifully lit and shot. Jack is sitting at a big desk. He's in shirt sleeves and suspenders looking quietly tough.
这一个拍得灯光亮丽。Jack坐在大桌子旁。他穿着衬衫，戴着背带，看起来沉稳而强硬。
But bad things happen to good people. And if it should happen to you, you're going to want someone like me by your side. And around here, there's only one someone like me.
但坏事总会发生在好人身上。如果你遇到了这种情况，你会想要像我这样的人在你身边。而在这一带，像我这样的人只有一个。
Jack Bailey is 64. And for over 30 years, he's made his money on workplace accidents, car crashes, medical malpractice, that kind of thing. Jack likes to call himself a podunk shirtsleeve lawyer. But he's been really successful. He wears monogrammed shirts under those suspenders. He's got a huge stately office with bayonets and a Don't Tread on Me flag on the wall.
Jack Bailey 64岁了。30多年来，他靠处理工作事故、车祸、医疗事故等这类事情赚钱。Jack喜欢称自己为乡下的便装律师。但他非常成功。他在背带下面穿的是绣有名字缩写的衬衫。他有一间豪华的办公室，墙上挂着刺刀和“别踩我”的旗帜。
He's got a showy dog too, a bull terrier that hangs out with him all day.
他还有一只引人注目的狗，一只终日陪着他的牛头梗。
Oh yeah, he's friendly. Hey Tater, somebody wants to meet you. Tater, wake up.
噢，是的，他很友好。嘿Tater，有人想见你。Tater，醒醒。
Jack's always liked doing this kind of work. He gets to pick his clients, make his own schedule. He finds out he's been assigned Trastavien's case in April 2015 when a fax comes in, a single-page court order. Jack picks it up, looks at it.
Jack一直喜欢做这种工作。他可以挑选客户，自己安排时间。2015年4月，当传真传来一张单页法院命令时，他发现自己被分配处理Trastavien的案子。Jack拿起它，看了一眼。
And he's very unhappy, and his face was kind of red.
他非常不高兴，脸都涨红了。
This is Tammy Burdine. She's been Jack's paralegal for over a decade. Jack took the fax to his office, made a racket. He was yelling to himself.
这是Tammy Burdine。她担任Jack的律师助理已经十多年了。Jack把传真带回办公室，闹得鸡飞狗跳。他在对自己大吼大叫。
He was in his office for a little while and he came out and he made the comment to me, well, it looks like we're representing a damn criminal.
他在办公室待了一会儿，出来后对我说了句，好吧，看来我们得为一个该死的罪犯辩护了。
The court order was a form letter. Jack's name was scribbled into a blank. He still has it.
法院命令是一份格式信。Jack的名字被草率地写在一个空白处。他现在还留着它。
Therefore, it is ordered that Attorney Jack Bailey be appointed to represent the defendant in this matter. By the way, it doesn't say this, but for free at my cost. Because it cost hundreds of dollars an hour to operate my office. So I'm actually paying to represent somebody. This isn't free.
因此，命令律师Jack Bailey被指派代理本案被告。顺便说一下，虽然上面没写，但这得由我自费。因为运营我的办公室每小时要花几百美元。所以我实际上是在花钱去为某人辩护。这可不是免费的。
Tammy was doing her best not to panic over how she and Jack were going to handle the case they'd been assigned. Because Jack doesn't do criminal cases. He doesn't deal with people facing prison time. But Tammy knew that Jack had at least dabbled in criminal cases for a few months early in his career. Maybe they'd be OK.
Tammy尽力不因她和Jack将如何处理被指派的案件而惊慌。因为Jack不处理刑事案件。他不接触面临监禁的人。但Tammy知道Jack在职业生涯早期至少在几个月内涉足过刑事案件。也许他们会没事的。
Surely law school taught him stuff about criminals. Surely somebody taught them something about criminal.
法律学校肯定教过他关于罪犯的事情。肯定有人教过他们一些刑事方面的知识。
I hadn't read the Louisiana Code of Criminal Procedure in over 30 years when I got this appointment.
当我接到这个指派时，我已经30多年没读过路易斯安那州刑事诉讼法典了。
I guess I just thought, well, Mr. Bailey has practiced long enough. He's a lawyer. He knows what to do.
我想我只是认为，好吧，Bailey先生执业够久了。他是个律师。他知道该怎么做。
I'm upset. I'm worried about whether I'm going to be able to do a good job or not. I'm worried about how much time I'm gonna have to invest in it. There is nothing good to say about it.
我很沮丧。我很担心自己能否做得好。我担心我得投入多少时间。这件事没一点好处。
So Jack came up with a plan. He thought the appointment had to be illegal. So he told Tammy, get me out of this.
所以Jack想出了一个计划。他认为这个指派一定是违法的。所以他告诉Tammy，帮我弄掉这个。
She started drafting letters of complaint to send off to the judge and to the public defenders. But because she was worried they might get stuck with the case, on her own, she started doing something else. She started working it.
她开始起草投诉信，准备寄给法官和公设辩护人。但因为担心会被这个案子缠住，她自作主张做了另一件事。她开始着手处理案子。
Tammy is super organized. Wire-rimmed glasses, late 40s, a smoker. And because Jack hasn't told her to do this work, she has to hide her tracks. When she wants to call the clerk of court to ask a question she makes sure she's out of earshot of Jack's office. Her desk is right outside his door.
Tammy非常专业。戴着金属框眼镜，40多岁，是个烟民。因为Jack没让她做这些工作，她必须隐藏踪迹。当她想给法庭书记员打电话问问题时，她会确保避开Jack办公室的听力范围。她的办公桌就在他的门外。
He would come out of his office and I'm minimizing WordPerfect. And I'm on Caddo's website. And I hear, you can hear his chair go creak. And I'm like, oh, crap. Here he comes. He's up, he's up. And I'm closing things.
他会从办公室出来，而我正在最小化WordPerfect。我正开着Caddo的网站。然后我听到，你可以听到他的椅子发出吱呀声。我在想，噢，糟糕。他来了。他站起来了，他站起来了。我在关掉窗口。
And I'm trying my best. I don't want to poke-- we laugh about it here, but the rule is you don't poke the bear. And I am worried about him seeing things on my computer poking the bear. But I have to, but I was told he didn't want us to. And I'm so confused on this whole case on every level.
我在尽力而为。我不想惹——我们在这里拿这个开玩笑，但规则是你不能惹火烧身。我担心他看到我电脑上的东西，那是在招惹麻烦。但我不得不做，虽然我被告知他不想让我们处理。在这个案子的各个层面上我都感到非常困惑。
She started where any of us would, Google. First she looks at the basics of criminal procedure in Louisiana and also the basics of her own case. The state had given them almost nothing. On the court order there wasn't even a charge listed, just a docket number and the guy's name, Trastavien Hardy.
她从任何一个人都会用的工具开始，谷歌。首先她查看了路易斯安那州刑事诉讼的基础知识，以及她自己案子的基础知识。州政府几乎什么都没给他们。在法院命令上甚至没写指控，只有一个案卷号和那个人的名字，Trastavien Hardy。
In her googling, Tammy finds a mug shot and a rap sheet. Trastavien is 25 and his record goes back years. There is a marijuana possession, a car break in, and he's a registered sex offender. But that's all she can find.
在谷歌搜索中，Tammy找到了入狱照和前科单。Trastavien 25岁，他的记录可以追溯到几年前。有持有大麻、闯入汽车记录，他还是注册性犯罪者。但那就是她能找到的所有信息了。
So she just waits. She assumes that the DA's office or the court is going to send more information.
所以她只是等着。她认为地方检察官办公室或法院会寄来更多信息。
I mean, you know, if you watch the TV shows, the Law & Order , the Criminal Minds , they have evidence. We have evidence in the civil matters. So I assumed the rest of it was coming, maybe in a box or a big envelope. And it never came. It just didn't.
我是说，你知道，如果你看电视节目，比如《法律与秩序》、《犯罪心理》，他们会有证据。我们在民事案件中有证据。所以我以为其余的资料会寄过来，也许放在盒子里或者大信封里。但它从来没来。就是没来。
A month passed. Then on May 13--
一个月过去了。然后是5月13日——
The phone rings and the receptionist answers it and he transfers the call and says Mr. Bailey, the court is on the phone. So he picks it up, this is Jack Bailey. And I can hear Mr. Bailey from where I sit. And he is telling them nobody told us about this date. And nobody said, and I wasn't aware. And you know, we'd missed the date.
电话响了，前台接了电话并转接过来，说Bailey先生，法院来电话了。他接起来，说我是Jack Bailey。我从坐的地方能听到Bailey先生的声音。他在告诉对方没人告诉我们这个日期。没人说，我也不知道。你知道，我们错过了那个日期。
They'd missed a court date on Trastavien's case. Tammy took a closer look at the faxed court order. There it was.
他们错过了Trastavien案子的出庭日期。Tammy仔细看了那份传真法院命令。上面确实写着。
It actually is just handwritten at the bottom of the order and it looks like 5.13. And I know it says court date, but it is bad handwriting.
它其实只是手写在命令底部，看起来像是5.13。我知道它写着出庭日期，但这字迹太烂了。
Of course, there was one person who managed to show up in court that day. He was brought there directly from jail.
当然，有一个人那天成功出庭了。他被直接从监狱带到了那里。
At that time, I really was just lost.
那时，我真的很迷茫。
Jack's client, Trastavien Hardy. He'd come to the courtroom in shackles hoping to finally meet his lawyer. But a bailiff in the courtroom told Trastavien that he hadn't seen Jack at all. Lots of these appointed attorneys weren't showing up.
Jack的客户，Trastavien Hardy。他戴着镣铐来到法庭，希望能终于见到他的律师。但法庭的一名法警告诉Trastavien，他根本没看到Jack。很多这些被指派的律师都没出现。
You know, I asked him like, where my lawyer at, who my lawyer is. And he  like, you probably never going to get to see him. He'll never really come to court. That's all he just said. Like you'll never get to see him in court. I'm like, dang.
你知道，我问他，我的律师在哪，我的律师是谁。他说，你可能永远也见不到他。他永远不会真的出庭的。他只说了这些。就像你在法庭上永远见不到他一样。我在想，该死。
Trastavien was eager to see an attorney because he says he hadn't done the burglary. It's true he used to be mixed up in some bad stuff. He'd pled guilty to those things Tammy had read about, though they weren't all as bad as she'd imagined. That registered sex offense, for example, it was consensual. Trastavien was 17, his girlfriend was 14, which at the time was a felony in Louisiana. He served time for it.
Trastavien渴望见到律师，因为他说他没有入室行窃。没错，他过去确实卷入过一些坏事。他曾对Tammy读到的那些事情认罪，尽管它们并不像她想象的那么严重。例如那个注册性犯罪，那是双方自愿的。Trastavien 17岁，他女朋友14岁，这在当时的路易斯安那州是重罪。他为此服刑了。
Trastavien is slight and soft spoken. Says yes sir a lot. You have to lean in a bit to hear him sometimes.
Trastavien瘦小且说话温和。经常说“是的，先生”。你有时必须凑近一点才能听清他的话。
And he says that since he got out of prison in 2011, he'd been keeping his nose clean. He was 25. He was a full-time student at a local college. He had just started dating someone, a nurse. He'd been sitting in jail since April terrified, upset, confused. He wanted to get back to his school, to his girlfriend.
他说自从2011年出狱后，他就一直安分守己。他25岁了。他是当地一所大学的全日制学生。他刚开始和人约会，是一个护士。他从4月起就一直待在监狱里，感到惊恐、沮丧和困惑。他想回到学校，回到他女朋友身边。
At his first court date he found out that the Caddo public defender's office couldn't offer him a lawyer, so he went back to his cell, waited for a month. Then on May 13, he went to court and his new lawyer, some guy named Jack Bailey, didn't even bother to show.
在第一次出庭时，他发现卡多公设辩护人办公室无法为他提供律师，所以他回到牢房，等了一个月。然后在5月13日，他出庭了，他的新律师，一个叫Jack Bailey的家伙，甚至懒得露面。
Back in his cell, Trastavien sat down and wrote a letter to Alan Golden, the chief public defender in Caddo.
回到牢房里，Trastavien坐下来写了一封信给卡多首席公设辩护人Alan Golden。
Dear Mr. Alan Golden, I was told you were the person to contact as far as reassigning me another public defender.
尊敬的Alan Golden先生，有人告诉我你是负责为我重新分配另一位公设辩护人的联系人。
Trastavien noted that Jack Bailey had ditched his court date, never tried to contact him, never visited him in jail.
Trastavien指出Jack Bailey错过了他的出庭日期，从未试图联系他，从未在监狱探视过他。
So I would like to fire him and be appointed someone who is going to fight for me. Thanks for your time, and I hope this letter don't go unnoticed. Sincerely, Trastavien Hardy.
所以我想要解雇他，并被指派一位会为我而战的人。感谢你的时间，希望这封信不会被忽视。诚挚地，Trastavien Hardy。
There's one word here, it looks like you went over it several times with the pen. It's pretty thick there. What's the word there?
这里有一个词，看起来你用笔反复划过了好几次。那里挺厚的。那是什么词？
Fire. Fire.
解雇。解雇。
Trastavien couldn't fire Jack, of course. There wasn't a backup lawyer to assign to him. Meanwhile, Jack had been sending off his own letters trying to get removed from the case. And by June, he and Tammy realized it wasn't going to work. Jack was stuck with Trastavien, just like Trastavien was stuck with him.
当然，Trastavien没法解雇Jack。没有后备律师可以指派给他。与此同时，Jack也一直在寄出他自己的信件试图退出案件。到了6月，他和Tammy意识到这行不通。Jack被Trastavien缠住了，就像Trastavien被Jack缠住一样。
First step, now that Jack was on board, he needed to visit Trastavien. But in order to get into the jail the warden said that he need a bar card, some kind of photo ID that the Louisiana State Bar Association issues. Jack had never needed a bar card in his civil practice. He was fuming.
第一步，现在Jack已经上船了，他需要去探望Trastavien。但为了进入监狱，监狱长说他需要律师执业证，某种路易斯安那州律师协会颁发的带照片的证件。Jack在民事业务中从未需要过律师执业证。他怒火中烧。
Yeah, listen, I'm sort of-- don't take this wrong way, but I'm kind of a big fish in a small pond. I've been here 40 years. I'm in the phone book. I was on the spine of the book. I periodically run TV advertisements.
是的，听着，我有点——别误会，我算是在小池塘里的一条大鱼。我在这儿40年了。我在电话簿里。我就在书的侧边。我定期投放电视广告。
I mean, everybody knows me. The sheriff lives down the street from my mama on Moss Point Road. The sheriff has known me for 30 years. And they're telling me I gotta get a bar code to come in as an appointed lawyer to see some poor bastard that's locked up in the jail? I mean, really, theater of the absurd.
我是说，每个人都知道我。治安官就住在Moss Point路的妈妈家附近。治安官认识我30年了。他们却告诉我，我得弄个律师执业证才能进去作为指派律师去见一个被关在监狱里的可怜混蛋？我是说，真的，荒诞剧。
They wasted two weeks to get the whole bar card thing sorted out. And then finally, almost two months after getting his appointment, Jack was going to meet his client. So Jack is sitting in the visiting room waiting for Trastavien.
他们浪费了两周时间才把律师执业证的事情搞定。最后，在得到指派近两个月后，Jack终于要去见他的客户了。所以Jack坐在探视室里等着Trastavien。
He comes in, I introduce myself. He doesn't know who I am. I have to explain to him who I am, what I'm doing there.
他进来了，我介绍了自己。他不知道我是谁。我得向他解释我是谁，我在那里做什么。
So then he starts telling me, I need to get out of jail. I need to get out of jail. I've lost my job. I've had to drop out of school. Well, the first thing I'm telling him is whoa, slow up, man. You know, tell me about what happened. Are you guilty of this or not?
然后他开始告诉我，我需要出狱。我需要出狱。我丢了工作。我不得不退学。好吧，我告诉他的第一件事就是，哇，慢点，伙计。你知道，告诉我发生了什么事。你真的犯了这个罪吗？
Trastavien said he wasn't guilty. He said he didn't know anything about the burglary. But Jack pointed to the warrant which said Trastavien's DNA had been collected from a hat. Trastavien explained that he'd had lots of hats over the years. He'd collected hats. He'd lost hats. He'd traded hats. Even if his DNA was on a hat at the scene, it wasn't proof he'd been there. Jack believed him.
Trastavien说他没犯罪。他说他对入室盗窃一无所知。但Jack指着逮捕令，上面写着Trastavien的DNA是从一顶帽子上采集的。Trastavien解释说他多年来有很多帽子。他收集帽子。他丢过帽子。他交易过帽子。即使他的DNA在现场的帽子上，也不是他去过那里的证据。Jack相信他。
You know, look, if you're a good trial lawyer you can detect the BS, right? OK. I mean, you get pretty good at it. I just walked out of there and my gut was telling me this kid wasn't guilty of what he was charged with.
你知道，听着，如果你是一个好的庭审律师，你可以察觉到谎言，对吧？好吧。我是说，你在这方面相当在行。我刚从那里走出来，直觉告诉我这个孩子并没有犯他被指控的罪行。
Also, if he had done this burglary, he would have had more information to give me. I don't find that clients are shy about sharing information with their lawyer, OK. So it's not like the other conversations I had in my career with criminal defendants that were guilty.
另外，如果他真的做了这次入室盗窃，他会提供更多信息给我。我发现客户在和他们的律师分享信息时并不害羞，好吧。所以这和我职业生涯中遇到的其他有罪的刑事被告的对话不一样。
Because let me tell you, they all know what's going on. And they all ask you, well, does the state know about this? What witnesses do they have? Did they find this? And Mr. Hardy knew precious little about this.
因为让我告诉你，他们都知道发生了什么。他们都会问你，好吧，政府知道这个吗？他们有什么证人？他们找到了这个吗？而Hardy先生对这些了解甚少。
Jack was suddenly invested in the case. Up till now he'd assumed Trastavien was probably guilty. In his experience, that's true of most people accused of crimes. Around the office, Jack had been calling Trastavien "our criminal."
Jack突然对这个案子投入进去了。直到现在，他一直认为Trastavien可能是有罪的。根据他的经验，大多数被指控犯罪的人确实如此。在办公室里，Jack一直称Trastavien为“我们的罪犯”。
But now he was ready to fight for him, go to trial. Which presented a problem. His client didn't want to do that. Unlike Jack, Trastavien did have some recent experience in the criminal justice system. He'd stood in front of a lot of judges. He'd spent three years in prison. And he knew most everybody takes a plea. Nobody goes to trial. He told Jack--
但现在他准备为他而战，进行审判。这带来了一个问题。他的客户不想那样做。不像Jack，Trastavien确实在刑事司法系统中有一些近期的经验。他站在很多法官面前过。他在监狱里待了三年。他知道大多数人都选择了认罪协议。没人会去进行审判。他告诉Jack——
I'll just plead guilty to anything within a year to go home. I'm like, I just want to go home. I could take a year of something, two years of probation.
我宁愿就任何事情认罪，只要能在一年内回家。我就想回家。我可以接受一年的刑期，或者两年缓刑。
So you were saying you were ready to plead guilty to just about anything if you could get out in a year. I mean, you've kind of--
所以你的意思是，只要能在一年内出狱，你就愿意就任何事情认罪。我是说，你已经有点——
Misdemeanor, that's what I was really trying to just get a misdemeanor.
轻罪，我只是想争取一个轻罪。
But Jack was not hearing that. He wanted a trial.
但Jack没听这个。他想要审判。
Did Jack explain to you that he was not a criminal defense attorney?
Jack有没有向你解释过他不是刑事辩护律师？
Oh, yes, sir. He had let me know that from the beginning.
哦，有的，先生。他从一开始就让我知道了。
How did you react when you heard this was his first criminal case in like 30 years?
当你听说这是他30年来第一个刑事案件时，你有什么反应？
I really was like, after I just really sat down and talked to him I was like at peace. Like, I know I'm in here. I know somebody, somebody came to see me. I know somebody that wants to help me.
我真的，在我坐下来和他真正交谈后，我感到平静。就像，我知道我在这里。我知道有人，有人来看我了。我知道有人想要帮助我。
So now Jack had to prepare a case. Luckily, Tammy had been doing all that secret work on the case behind Jack's back. Or not so secret, it turns out. Turns out the bear knows what's going on in his woods.
所以现在Jack必须准备案子。幸运的是，Tammy一直在Jack背后秘密处理这个案子。或者说并不那么秘密，事实证明。事实证明熊知道它的森林里发生了什么。
Well yeah, I walk right by her desk all the time. I see what's up on her computer screen.
嗯，是的，我一直走过她的桌子。我能看到她电脑屏幕上的内容。
By the time they got to trial, Tammy worked up a master timeline, a list of evidence, a list of evidence and discovery not produced, questions to use in cross-examination, and 126 pages of details on other possible suspects.
当他们进入审判时，Tammy整理出了一份主时间表、一份证据清单、一份未提供的证据和开示清单、交叉询问的问题，以及126页关于其他可能嫌疑人的详细信息。
June 22, 2015, on this date, Jack and Trastavien had their first preliminary examination. Basically, it was a pre-trial court date where the DA was supposed to outline their case against Trastavien and prove why he should still be held in jail. Now remember, Jack and Trastavien were going to walk into court and plead not guilty. That was the plan.
2015年6月22日，在这一天，Jack和Trastavien进行了第一次初步审查。基本上，这是一个审前庭日期，地区检察官应该在这里概述针对Trastavien的案件，并证明为什么他应该继续被关在监狱里。现在记住，Jack和Trastavien要走进法庭并拒绝认罪。那是计划。
But in court that day, Trastavien got cold feet.
但在那天法庭上，Trastavien退缩了。
When he walks in and he comes up to the counsel table, when they brought him down from the jail. First thing he said to me was--
当他走进来，来到律师桌前，当他们把他从监狱带下来的时候。他对我说的第一件事就是——
I plead guilty right now.
我现在就认罪。
That is, cop a plea, take a deal, no trial.
也就是，达成协议，接受交易，不进行审判。
I said no, you're not doing that. And he goes, but I want to. And I said shut up. Just trust me for a minute.
我说不，你不会那样做的。他说，但我想要。我说闭嘴。先信任我一下。
His confidence, it's how he talk with that baritone voice, you can't help but be like, well yes, sir. I'm going to just sit back and let you do it then.
他的自信，那种他用男中音说话的方式，你忍不住会觉得，好吧，是的，先生。那我还是坐下来让你来处理吧。
I'm sure that here I was, this old, rich, fat, ugly, white guy telling this young black man the way of the world and the lay of the land. And I'm sure he thought man, what have I gotten stuck with?
我敢肯定，当时我作为一个又老、又有钱、又胖、又丑的白人，告诉这个年轻的黑人这个世界的规矩。我敢肯定他在想，天哪，我这是被什么人缠上了？
I've talked to a couple defense attorneys about Jack's strategy to go to trial. And they agreed it was risky. A public defender who was in the courtroom that day told me she thought it was reckless. Because first of all, if your client is interested in a plea deal, you're supposed to explore that, see what the DA might be willing to offer. Jack refused to do that.
我和几个辩护律师谈过Jack要去审判的策略。他们一致认为这很冒险。那天在法庭上的一位公设辩护人告诉我，她认为这很鲁莽。因为首先，如果你的客户对认罪协议感兴趣，你应该去探讨它，看看地区检察官可能愿意提供什么。Jack拒绝这样做。
And Trastavien was right, he really could face a lot more time if he went to trial. This was, after all, Caddo Parish.
而且Trastavien是对的，如果他真的去审判，他确实可能面临更多刑期。这毕竟是卡多教区。
Caddo Parish is unique for how harsh their system is and can be.
卡多教区因其体制严厉而独树一帜。
This is Derwyn Bunton, a public defender who spent the early part of his career working cases in Caddo. These days, he's the chief public defender across the state in New Orleans.
这是Derwyn Bunton，一位在职业生涯早期曾在卡多处理案件的公设辩护人。如今，他是全州路易斯安那州新奥尔良的首席公设辩护人。
Caddo Parish has a reputation for tough, long sentences. And up until recently, led the state in capital convictions, in death sentences for a number of years.
卡多教区以严厉、长期判决而闻名。直到最近，多年来一直领先全州进行死刑判决。
Derwyn told me the story of one case he handled in Caddo. He was representing a 14-year-old who coincidentally was charged with the same crime as Trastavien, simple burglary of an inhabited dwelling.
Derwyn给我讲了他曾在卡多处理的一个案子的故事。他代表一名14岁的少年，巧合的是，他被指控的罪名和Trastavien一样，即简单入室盗窃居住房屋。
And the allegation was he went into a neighbor's house without permission and took a Pepsi and a Hot Pocket. So he drank the Pepsi, ate the Hot Pocket, knew the neighbor. He got caught. And he got sentenced to seven years. He was going to stay in juvenile prison until he was 21.
指控称他未经许可进入邻居家，拿了一瓶百事可乐和一个热口袋。所以他喝了百事可乐，吃了热口袋，认识邻居。他被抓住了。他被判了七年。他得待在少年监狱直到21岁。
And I just thought that there was some sort of typo. No damage, no one was hurt, and he was 14. And they're going to leave him in jail till he's essentially a grown man. We were able to get him out early with some good work. But they gave him seven years without blinking and didn't even go to trial. That's Caddo Parish.
我当时只是认为那一定是打字错误。没有损坏，没人受伤，而且他才14岁。他们竟然要让他待在监狱里直到他基本上变成一个成年人。我们通过一些出色的工作让他提前出来了。但他们毫不眨眼地判了他七年，甚至都没进行审判。这就是卡多教区。
Attorneys told me if Trastavien took a plea, he'd probably get about the same as that teenager, five to eight years. But if you push for trial in lost, the minimum he'd get, given his priors, would be 20 years. And he could get life.
律师们告诉我，如果Trastavien选择认罪，他可能得到和那个青少年差不多的判决，五到八年。但如果你坚持审判而输掉，考虑到他的前科，他至少会得到20年。而且他可能被判终身监禁。
So through the summer, Jack and Trastavien have this series of pre-trial court dates. The main reason they're noteworthy is because at every one, Jack is being a giant pain in the ass, demanding a speedy trial, berating the young DA on this case, insisting they free Trastavien without bail.
所以整个夏天，Jack和Trastavien进行了一系列审前庭日期。他们值得注意的主要原因是，每一次Jack都在制造麻烦，要求快速审判，斥责处理此案的年轻地区检察官，坚持在没有保释金的情况下释放Trastavien。
Trastavien says people in the stands were oohing and ahhing at Jack's performance. One old woman said, God is good. A trial date was set for November 30. And the judge released Trastavien to wait out the days till trial at home. At that point, he'd spent 105 days in jail.
Trastavien说旁听席上的人对Jack的表现发出惊叹。一位老妇人说，上帝是仁慈的。审判日期定在11月30日。法官释放了Trastavien，让他回家等待审判。那时，他在监狱里待了105天。
Here's the riskiest thing about Jack's demand for a speedy trial, he demanded it without even knowing all the evidence the state had on Trastavien. Not till September did that big box of files Tammy was expecting finally come in from the DA's office. It was more of a packet, 54 pages stuffed into a manila envelope.
这是Jack要求快速审判最冒险的一点，他甚至不知道政府对Trastavien掌握的所有证据就提出了要求。直到9月，Tammy一直期待的那大箱档案才终于从地方检察官办公室寄来。那更像是一个数据包，塞进马尼拉纸信封的54页纸。
Tammy tore into it as soon as it came. And it turned out that the case against Trastavien was even weaker than they thought. Because the crime lab report, the one that pointed out Trastavien's DNA had been found on a hat, it said there was actually DNA from two people on the hat. Someone else besides Trastavien had worn that hat. So they had a good case after all.
Tammy一拿到就打开了。结果针对Trastavien的案子比他们想象的还要薄弱。因为犯罪实验室报告，也就是指出Trastavien的DNA在帽子上被发现的那份，上面说帽子上实际上有两个人的DNA。除了Trastavien之外还有别人戴过那顶帽子。所以他们毕竟有一个很好的案子。
It's the Saturday after Thanksgiving, two days before the trial that could send Trastavien away for decades. Jack and Tammy are supposed to be preparing, but when Tammy gets to the office--
那是感恩节后的星期六，距离可能让Trastavien入狱几十年的审判还有两天。Jack和Tammy应该正在准备，但当Tammy来到办公室时——
I have a note in my chair that says I'm sick.
我的椅子上有一张便条，写着我病了。
The note, of course, was from Jack. He came into work, just wanted to complain.
这张便条当然是Jack写的。他来到工作岗位，只是想抱怨。
I got some horrible Siberian death crud upper respiratory infection.
我得了可怕的西伯利亚死亡病毒，上呼吸道感染。
And I'm like what?
我心想什么？
Instead of being at home Thanksgiving with my family, Tammy and I are up here getting prepared for trial. We're working on PowerPoints, timelines.
感恩节没有和家人待在家里，Tammy和我却在这里为审判做准备。我们正在制作PowerPoint，时间表。
Preparing documents, making sure I's are dotted and T's are crossed. Because I'm freaking out. I am freaking out.
准备文件，确保每一处细节都无懈可击。因为我快疯了。我快疯了。
Years ago I had gotten a series of videotapes, VHS tapes from Gerry Spence about voir dire and opening statement.
几年前，我得到了一系列录像带，Gerry Spence关于陪审团挑选和开场陈词的VHS录像带。
Gerry Spence is a famed trial lawyer, a kind of legal guru. Voire dire is jury selection.
Gerry Spence是一位著名的庭审律师，某种法律大师。Voire dire就是陪审团挑选。
And I pulled my old TV out in the back that you can still play VHS tapes in. And I'm sitting in here, you know, drinking tea and eating ibuprofen and watching Gerry Spence tapes, taking notes to remember how to do this the right way, you know?
我把后面那台还能播放VHS录像带的旧电视机拉了出来。我坐在那儿，你知道，喝着茶，吃着布洛芬，看着Gerry Spence的录像带，做笔记，记着如何以正确的方式来做这件事，你知道吗？
Monday, November 30, the day of the trial. Jack, Tammy, and Trastavien all enter the court house. Jack's eager. He's ready. He loves this part of the job. But before anything official begins, the young DA on this case, Scott Brady, he pulls Jack aside and tells him something totally shocking. He's going to nolle pros the case.
11月30日星期一，审判日。Jack、Tammy和Trastavien都进入了法院。Jack很急切。他准备好了。他热爱工作的这一部分。但在任何正式程序开始之前，此案的年轻地区检察官Scott Brady把Jack拉到一边，告诉了他一件非常令人震惊的事。他要撤诉。
In other words, I'm dropping the charges. And at that point I said some things that I can't tell you if you're going to play them on the radio.
换句话说，我要撤销指控。在那一点上，我说了一些如果要在广播中播放我就不能告诉你的话。
Why don't  you tell us and then will determine if we--
为什么你不告诉我们，然后我们再决定是否——
That's my producer saying, why don't you tell us and we'll determine if we can play it.
那是我的制作人在说，为什么你不告诉我们，我们会决定是否能播放。
I said, you god damn mother fucking son of a bitch, you didn't read your goddamn file until this weekend, did you?
我说，你这个该死的他妈的混蛋，你直到这个周末才读你的档案，对吧？
In other words, you just realized how weak your case was. If you'd done that months ago you would have saved me and my client a lot of trouble. Scott Brady declined to comment for our story, but a colleague claims that he was ready for trial that day.
换句话说，你刚意识到你的案子有多薄弱。如果你几个月前这样做，你就会省去我和我客户很多麻烦。Scott Brady拒绝就我们的报道发表评论，但一位同事声称他那天已经准备好进行审判了。
So Jack has this side conversation with the DA and knows the charges against Trastavien are going to be dropped. But nobody else does. Not the judge, not Tammy and Trastavien, who are there after all these months of preparation waiting for the trial to start. The gavel strikes. The court's in session.
所以Jack和地区检察官进行了这次侧谈，知道针对Trastavien的指控要被撤销。但其他人不知道。不是法官，不是Tammy和Trastavien，他们在经过这几个月的准备后都在那里等待审判开始。法槌敲响。法庭开庭了。
We are first. The assistant DA gets up and says your honor, in the matter State vs. Trastavien Hardy, and then he says, your honor, the state is dismissing the charges with nothing else. And that was it.
我们是第一个。助理地方检察官站起来说，法官阁下，在State vs. Trastavien Hardy一案中，然后他说，法官阁下，政府撤销指控，没有别的了。就这样。
As soon as I walked up there I'm like, oh yes. Thank you, Jesus. That was the first thing I said, really. I was like thank you, Jesus. I really felt overwhelmed. I was like about time.
当我走上去时，我心想，噢耶。感谢耶稣。那是第一件我说的话，真的。我当时想感谢耶稣。我真的感到不知所措。我当时想终于到了。
But I'm all of a sudden going what? What just happened? We're here. We're ready. They just stomped the show. The show, is just-- but that's what I wanted. But then I won't know the outcome. But this is the outcome. But wait a minute, they need to know that Mr Hardy didn't do this.
但我突然在想什么？刚刚发生了什么？我们在这里。我们准备好了。他们就这样结束了演出。演出，就是——但这正是我想的。但我不会知道结果。但这就是结果。但等等，他们需要知道Hardy先生没做这件事。
And then Mr Bailey, he said, your honor--
然后Bailey先生，他说，法官阁下——
I refused to leave the courtroom without putting some things on the record.
我拒绝离开法庭，而不把一些事情记入记录。
Several defense attorneys told me this was a pretty crazy thing Jack was doing. The DA was ready to dismiss the charges. Normally, you'd say thank you and move on. What if Jack said something that made the DA change his mind? Tammy was worried.
几位辩护律师告诉我，Jack正在做的这件事相当疯狂。地区检察官已经准备好撤销指控。通常，你会说谢谢然后继续。如果Jack说了什么让地区检察官改变主意怎么办？Tammy很担心。
And now I'm going to pass out right here in this chair. What is he doing? What is happening? And Mr Hardy had been standing up there with him. And so he's really, he turns around and looks at me like is this OK?
而现在我就要晕倒在这把椅子上了。他在做什么？发生了什么？Hardy先生一直站在他旁边。所以他真的，他转过身看着我，好像在问这样可以吗？
Really just looked back like whoa, what's going on now?
确实只是回头看了看，好像在问，哇，现在发生什么了？
And I'm sure my look told him, this is not OK on any level. This is not OK. You should panic. Come sit down. Get away from him. Stop. Because I do know Mr. Bailey. And he's going to say what he believes needs to be said.
我敢肯定我的表情告诉他，这在任何层面上都不可以。这不可以。你应该恐慌。快坐下。离他远点。停下。因为我确实了解Bailey先生。他会说出他认为需要说出的话。
I said judge, I have a statement I want to make for the record to protect Mr Hardy in the future if this arrest prosecution is ever held against him if you don't mind. I said judge, this man is factually innocent. And I'm sorry the court is not going to get to see me excoriate the police and the district attorney's office in this case.
我说法官，我有一个声明要记入记录，以便在未来保护Hardy先生，如果这次逮捕起诉被视为对他不利，如果你不介意的话。我说法官，这个男人在事实上是无罪的。我很抱歉法庭将无法看到我在这个案件中严厉抨击警方和地区检察官办公室。
Jack's speech lasted about 10 minutes. He ranted about the scant evidence against his client, about the DA, about having to take this case at all.
Jack的演讲持续了大约10分钟。他咆哮着针对他客户的薄弱证据，针对地区检察官，针对不得不接这个案子本身。
So you can put on the record, judge, I'm angry, and I'm angry at the system.
所以你可以记入记录，法官，我很愤怒，我对这个体制感到愤怒。
When Jack was done, the judge then turned to Scott Brady and asked, Mr. DA, anything further? The DA, Scott Brady, answered the judge, no, sir. The matter has been dismissed. The judge turned to Trastavien, you're free to go, he said.
当Jack说完后，法官转向Scott Brady问道，地方检察官先生，还有什么吗？地区检察官Scott Brady回答法官，没有了，先生。事情已经被撤销了。法官转向Trastavien，你自由了，他说。
Since Scott Brady won't do an interview, we don't know why he dropped the case. There are a few factors here. The victim didn't show up in court. And the crime, in the scheme of things, wasn't that serious. But both public defenders who were in the courtroom that day told me they thought Jack might have been the deciding factor.
由于Scott Brady不做采访，我们不知道他为什么要撤销案子。这里有几个因素。受害者那天没出庭。而且在事情的发展中，犯罪并没有那么严重。但那天在法庭上的两位公设辩护人都告诉我，他们认为Jack可能是决定性因素。
One of them, Sarah Smith, said Jack made it clear he was going to fight tooth and nail on every procedural matter.
其中一位Sarah Smith说，Jack清楚地表明他会在每一个程序问题上针锋相对。
The motions that Jack was making, the 10 minute speeches, and not necessarily following the traditional order of this is how criminal court is supposed to work. Jack definitely wasn't making this an easy process.
Jack提出的动议，那10分钟的演讲，并不一定遵循传统的顺序，这是刑事法庭应该运作的方式。Jack绝对没有让这个过程变得容易。
She says a normal public defender doesn't have time to fight like that for all their clients. And once Jack made things so difficult, the DA might have decided he didn't have time to deal with it either.
她说，一个普通的公设辩护人没时间为他们所有的客户那样奋斗。而一旦Jack把事情变得如此困难，地方检察官可能决定他也没时间去处理了。
Trastavien's been free for over a year now. He got a job as a fry cook at a Sonic Drive-In. He says he wants to start school again next year. And he's got a little girl, Carla. He's spending a lot of time with her.
Trastavien已经自由一年多了。他在Sonic Drive-In找到了一份煎炸厨师的工作。他说他想明年重新开始上学。他有一个小女儿，Carla。他花了很多时间陪她。
Right as this story was taking place, Caddo Parish elected a new top DA, the first black DA in its history. One of his first actions was getting rid of nine assistant district attorneys in his office. Scott Brady, who prosecuted the case against Trastavien, was among them. Just this month, the public defender's office in Caddo Parish stopped the practice of farming out cases to private attorneys. Some funding came through, for now.
就在这个故事发生的同时，卡多教区选举了一位新的顶级地区检察官，这是该教区历史上第一位黑人地方检察官。他的第一个行动之一就是解雇办公室里的九名助理地方检察官。处理针对Trastavien案件的Scott Brady就在其中。就在本月，卡多教区的公设辩护人办公室停止了将案件分包给私人律师的做法。一些资金通过了，目前为止。
Jack, meanwhile, has been pushing for more funding for public defenders. He went to the Louisiana State Legislature, met with three state senators and the public defender lobbyist. He offered to testify. He said he'd do anything to help. He does not want another case like this.
与此同时，Jack一直在推动为公设辩护人提供更多资助。他去了路易斯安那州议会，会见了三名州参议员和公设辩护人的游说者。他主动提出作证。他说他会做任何事来帮忙。他不希望再有这样的案子。
David Zax. Coming up, how a public park in the suburbs of Virginia helped beat the Nazis. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
David Zax。接下来，弗吉尼亚州郊区的一个公共公园是如何帮助打败纳粹的。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Deep End of the Pool. Stories of people thrown into serious situations they have no skills for, where they have to figure out what to do on the fly. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Mein Camp.
这是《美国生活》，我是Ira Glass。当然，每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目，泳池深水区。关于人们被扔进他们没有技能的严重处境中的故事，他们必须在飞行中弄清楚该做什么。我们已经到达了我们节目的第二幕。第二幕，我的奋斗。
Sometimes an entire government has to dive into the deep end of the pool and do something it has never done before. One of our producers, Karen Duffin, has the story of the US government doing just that in a high stakes sink or swim situation. Though the reason we know about this government program at all is actually kind of an accident. Karen explains.
有时整个政府必须潜入深水区，做一些它从未做过的事。我们的制作人之一Karen Duffin，有关于美国政府在生死攸关的“沉还是游”情况下做这件事的故事。虽然我们了解这个政府计划的原因其实有点意外。Karen解释道。
Back in 2006, a woman named Sandy Gray decided to go on a tour of the park near her house in suburban Virginia. It's a national park, but less like Yellowstone, more like a neighborhood park-- soccer fields, softball diamonds, picnic pavilions. Over 100 acres. It's called Fort Hunt Park.
早在2006年，一位叫Sandy Gray的女士决定去弗吉尼亚州郊区她家附近的公园游览。这是一个国家公园，但不像黄石公园，更像是一个邻里公园——足球场、垒球场、野餐亭。超过100英亩。它叫Fort Hunt公园。
The park ranger ran through the history of the place. She told Sandy's group it had been part of George Washington's estate. She pointed to structures from the Spanish-American war. But when she got to World War II, she said that is a mystery.
公园管理员介绍了这个地方的历史。她告诉Sandy的小组，这曾经是乔治·华盛顿庄园的一部分。她指出了西班牙-美国战争时期的建筑。但当她谈到二战时，她说那是一个谜。
We know there was a secret military program here, code named PO Box 1142. She said the rangers had been trying for years to figure out what it was, even asked the Pentagon about it. But they said they thought the files had been destroyed.
我们知道这里有一个秘密军事计划，代号PO Box 1142。她说管理员们多年来一直试图弄清楚它是什么，甚至问过五角大楼。但他们说他们认为文件已经被销毁了。
And when we got to this point, she said we probably never will know the whole story.
当我们到达这一点时，她说我们可能永远不会知道全部真相。
This is Sandy. Turned out she knew something the rangers didn't.
这是Sandy。结果她知道一些管理员们不知道的事。
So I was thinking whether or not I should say anything because I was questioning whether I was supposed to know anything. So I raised my hand and I said you know, I think I can hook you up with someone who was here during that time.
所以我当时在想我是否应该说出来，因为我质疑我是否应该知道任何事情。所以我举手说你知道，我想我可以帮你联系一个在那期间在这里待过的人。
Sandy had never heard of PO Box 1142. But she remembered that her neighbor had said he'd worked at the site during the war. So she gave the rangers his name, Fred Michel. And later, back at the office, they huddled around a speaker phone and they dialed his number.
Sandy从未听说过PO Box 1142。但她记得她的邻居说过他在战争期间在那里工作过。所以她给了管理员们他的名字，Fred Michel。后来，回到办公室，他们挤在扬声器电话旁拨了他的号码。
The head park ranger at the time was Vince Santucci. He told Fred they were calling about PO Box 1142.
当时的首席公园管理员是Vince Santucci。他告诉Fred他们打电话是关于PO Box 1142的。
And there was a little bit of silence. And the first comment that comes back is how do you know about PO Box 1142? So we went in to explain what we were doing. And his response was that he's not able to share anything with us because he signed a secrecy agreement. In fact, that he didn't tell his wife of 65 years. And he said, I wish I could share it with you, but he couldn't.
有一点沉默。第一个回来的评价是你是怎么知道PO Box 1142的？所以我们解释了我们在做什么。他的回答是他不能和我们分享任何事情，因为他签署了保密协议。事实上，他甚至没告诉他结婚65年的妻子。他说，我希望我能和你分享，但他做不到。
The rangers hung up and panicked. They worried Fred might be their only shot. World War II vets were in their 80s, 90s, or dead. So they went back to the Pentagon. And said, we found a guy, but he won't talk. Can you help?
管理员们挂断电话并惊慌失措。他们担心Fred可能是他们唯一的希望。二战老兵当时已经80多岁、90多岁，或者去世了。所以他们回到五角大楼。说，我们找到了一个人，但他不肯说。你能帮忙吗？
So the director of Army Intelligence wrote Fred a letter clearing him to speak. Here's Vince.
所以陆军情报局局长给Fred写了一封信，清除他讲话的障碍。这是Vince。
And so when we forwarded that to Fred Michel, he said, OK, what do you want to know?
所以当我们把它转发给Fred Michel时，他说，好吧，你想知道什么？
The rangers went to Fred's house to interview him.
管理员们去了Fred家采访他。
I'm here in the home of Frederick and Lucille Michel conducting a series of oral history interviews about their memories of Fort Hunt.
我现在在Frederick和Lucille Michel的家中，进行一系列关于他们对Fort Hunt记忆的口述历史采访。
This is park ranger Brandon Bies. He did a lot of these interviews. And for 4 and 1/2 hours, Fred told them about PO Box 1142. Then he gave them more names.
这是公园管理员Brandon Bies。他做了很多这样的采访。在4个半小时里，Fred告诉他们关于PO Box 1142的事情。然后他给了他们更多的名字。
I was transferred to PO Box 1142.
我被转到了PO Box 1142。
They made more calls, did more interviews.
他们打了更多的电话，做了更多的采访。
We were told that we're not going to talk, not to our wives, not to anybody.
我们被告知我们要保持沉默，不能对我们的妻子，不能对任何人。
We got the photographs from the Pentagon. And everything--
我们从五角大楼得到了照片。还有一切——
They talked to 70 men. For over 60 years, these men had all been living with the same secret. This suburban park had been a top secret camp for interrogating Nazi prisoners of war. And the men doing the interrogations, they were Jews. Lots of them, anyway. European Jews who just fled the Nazis. Many still had family in concentration camps.
他们和70个人谈过。60多年来，这些人一直活在同一个秘密中。这个郊区公园曾经是一个审问纳粹战俘的绝密营地。而进行审问的人，他们是犹太人。很多人，至少是很多。逃离纳粹的欧洲犹太人。许多人仍有家人在集中营里。
These men were specifically recruited because they spoke German, and because they understood the nuances of German culture and psychology, slang, cultural references, small details that an American would miss. This was the American military's first attempt to create a program like this for interrogating prisoners. First time we approached interrogation in a systematic and strategic way, not just to learn things like where's the bomb about to go off, but to get a whole picture of the enemy's plans.
这些人被专门招募是因为他们会说德语，并且因为他们理解德国文化和心理的细微差别、俚语、文化参考、美国人会错过的微小细节。这是美国军方第一次尝试创建这样一个审问程序。我们第一次以系统和战略的方式接近审问，不仅仅是为了了解炸弹在哪里要爆炸，而是为了得到敌人计划的整体图景。
And they were figuring out how to do this in the middle of the deadliest armed conflict in world history. And they succeeded. By the end of the war, they'd extracted a ton of really important intelligence about where the Allies should bomb, about German weapons still being developed, about the structure of the German Army. One of the Enigma machines was captured using intel discovered at PO Box 1142.
他们当时正在想如何在世界历史上最致命的武装冲突中弄清楚如何做这件事。而且他们成功了。战争结束时，他们提取了大量关于盟军应该在哪里轰炸、关于仍在开发的德国武器、关于德国军队结构的非常重要的情报。其中一台Enigma机器是在利用在PO Box 1142发现的情报捕获的。
The approach they used didn't include any kind of physical force. In the hundreds of previously classified files that I've read, torture is never considered. Instead, they used this approach. This is from a World War II interrogation training film.
他们使用的方法不包括任何形式的身体力量。在我读过的数百份之前被列为机密的文件中，从未考虑过酷刑。相反，他们使用了这种方法。这是来自二战审问培训电影。
Make your interrogation as casual as possible. Try to make the prisoner feel that you're his friend, the first one he's met since his capture.
使你的审问尽可能随意。尽量让囚犯感觉到你是他的朋友，他是被捕以来遇到的第一个朋友。
All are human underneath. Our interrogator's job is to play upon those weaknesses, to help make up the complete intelligence picture.
所有人在内心深处都是人类。我们审问者的工作就是利用那些弱点，帮助构建完整的情报图景。
And here's a mock interrogation from the film.
这是电影中的模拟审问。
Why did you have this Spanish dictionary in your plane?
你为什么要在飞机上放这本西班牙语字典？
Just improving my mind.
只是为了改善我的思想。
Who do you think you're fooling, Tenetti? Your name is right there on the cover. Why were you flying back to Spain? You must not lie to me.
你以为你在愚弄谁，Tenetti？你的名字就在封面上。你为什么飞回西班牙？你不能对我撒谎。
I only tell the truth.
我只说实话。
Now don't try to give me that routine.
现在不要试着给我那套程序。
Time. Time, gentlemen. We'll stop there. I'm going to ask for criticisms. Any volunteers? Yes, lieutenant?
时间。时间，先生们。我们就停在那儿。我要请求批评。有志愿者吗？是的，中尉？
It's not good to lose your temper that way, especially with such a dumb, good-natured type.
那样发脾气不好，尤其是对这种愚蠢、随和的类型。
It seems self-evident now, but at the time, it was sort of a revelation that you could get information by playing on a prisoner's psychology. At the end of another mock interrogation, the instructor reviewed what worked on that prisoner.
现在看来是不言自明的，但在当时，通过利用囚犯的心理来获取信息是一种启示。在另一次模拟审问结束时，导师回顾了对那个囚犯什么管用。
You noticed how he won the prisoner's gratitude by promising to inform his family of his safety. How he established immediate contact through mutual interest in the Munich theater. How he played on the Bavarian's prejudice against his Prussian lieutenant. How he pretended to know more about the new Heinkel 177s than the Sergeant, thereby piquing his vanity and causing him to talk. As a result, he is now in possession of valuable information.
你注意到他是如何通过承诺通知他的家人他的安全来赢得囚犯的感激了吗？他是如何通过对慕尼黑剧院的共同兴趣建立即时联系的？他是如何利用巴伐利亚人对他的普鲁士中尉的偏见来打牌的？他是如何假装比中士更了解新的Heinkel 177，从而激起他的虚荣心并导致他说话的。结果，他现在拥有了有价值的信息。
It's like a high stakes game of psychological poker. To win, you have to see the enemy in front of you as a nuanced human. They were taught that even feeling too much hostility about the enemy would blind them.
这就像是一场高风险的心理扑克游戏。为了赢，你必须把你面前的敌人视为一个细微的人。他们被教导说，即使对敌人感觉太多的敌意也会使他们盲目。
I spent years studying this camp. And what I wanted to know was the most basic thing. What it was like for these Jewish men facing off with the Nazis in such a personal way. Facing people who'd driven some of them out of their country, killed their families.
我花了几年时间研究这个营地。而我想知道的是最基本的事情。对于这些犹太人来说，以这样一种私人的方式面对纳粹是什么感觉。面对那些把他们中的一些人赶出国、杀害了他们家人的人。
So I pestered the government until they released over 1,000 pages of interviews with these guys. And I personally spoke with 10 of them or their families if they weren't still alive. And in this mountain of material, many of them said they were happy to do the work. It meant helping beat the Nazis.
所以我一直纠缠政府，直到他们发布了1000多页对这些家伙的采访。而且我亲自和其中10个人或他们的家人谈过，如果他们还没去世的话。在这堆山一样的材料中，许多人说他们很高兴做这份工作。这意味着帮助打败纳粹。
But some had more complicated feelings, like this guy, Paul Fairbrook, who the park rangers interviewed in 2008. He was German, Jewish. Said he agreed with not using force on the Nazis, but befriending them, no way.
但有些人有更复杂的感情，比如这个家伙，Paul Fairbrook，公园管理员在2008年采访了他。他是德国人，犹太人。说他同意不对纳粹使用武力，但与他们交朋友，没门。
Many of us German Jewish soldiers resented the fact that some of our offices were fraternizing with German officers, Nazis. Because every German officer was a Nazi, you know. And here we are fighting as German Jews for America and these jerks, our officers, are fraternizing with the people who were our enemies.
我们中的许多德国犹太士兵对我们的一些办公室在与德国军官、纳粹分子亲善感到不满。因为每个德国军官都是纳粹，你知道。而我们在这里作为德国犹太人为美国而战，而这些混蛋，我们的军官，却在与我们的敌人亲善。
But then there was this guy, Henry Kolm. He says that working that closely with the Nazis changed his opinion of them.
但后来有这个家伙，Henry Kolm。他说与纳粹如此密切地工作改变了他对他们的看法。
When you get to know somebody one-on-one you know, it's a different story. It proved to me that there are decent people in Germany, despite the Third Reich and Nazi and Hitler and all the rest of it.
当你一对一了解某人时，你知道，这是另一回事。它证明了尽管有第三帝国和纳粹和希特勒以及所有这一切，德国仍有体面的人。
He genuinely liked some of them. But still, when he was assigned to guard duty, he took extra precautions, just in case the prisoners realized he was Jewish.
他真心喜欢其中一些人。但仍然，当他被指派到守卫职责时，他采取了额外的预防措施，以防万一囚犯意识到他是犹太人。
And I often spent all day inside that stockade. And that was not a very comfortable feeling. I had a pistol in my sock.
我经常整天待在那个围栏里面。那感觉真不舒服。我在袜子里放了一把手枪。
He said he had a pistol in his sock. They didn't normally carry guns.
他说他在袜子里放了一把手枪。他们通常不携带枪支。
Yeah, I didn't feel very happy in a courtyard surrounded by 60 German soldiers, prisoners. You know, I'm Jewish, and they might have known that.
是的，我在一个被60名德国士兵、囚犯包围的庭院里感觉不太好。你知道，我是犹太人，他们可能知道这一点。
But in the 80 or so hours of interviews, I found only one incident where someone who was trained at 1142 just flipped out on a German prisoner.
但在80多小时的采访中，我只发现了一个事件，在1142受过训练的人对德国囚犯失去了理智。
I'm going to talk as it comes out of my mouth.
我要说出它从我嘴里出来的样子。
That's that point.
这是那个点。
This is Werner Moritz. He died in 2010, so I never met him, but I talked with his daughter. She said he was a man of strong opinions, the kind of man who walks into a room and tells a joke just so that you he's there. Sharp dresser, mustache always neatly trimmed. He spent two years at PO Box 1142, where he says he was trained like everyone else not to mistreat prisoners. And he never did at the camp.
这是Werner Moritz。他于2010年去世，所以我从未见过他，但我与他的女儿谈过。她说他是一个有强烈观点的人，那种走进房间讲个笑话只是为了让你知道他在那儿的男人。衣着光鲜，胡子总是修剪得很整齐。他在PO Box 1142待了两年，他说他像其他人一样被训练不要虐待囚犯。他在营地里从未这样做过。
But near the end of the war, Werner was sent to Europe to help find and interrogate Nazis who now understood they were losing and were hiding out.
但在战争快结束时，Werner被派往欧洲，帮助寻找和审问现在明白他们正在失败并躲藏起来的纳粹。
We were given orders at that point, he said, to just roam around. Find the Nazis. Find the bigwigs, find the big shots. So we started to roam.
当时我们接到命令，他说，四处转转。找到纳粹。找到大人物，找到大腕。所以我们开始四处转转。
And one day, he says he found a high ranking Nazi named Julius Streicher. Streicher was a friend of Hitler. He had masterminded some of the nastiest anti-semitic propaganda. His newspaper, Der Stürmer, played a huge role in fueling the hatred towards the Jews that led to the Holocaust. The paper's tag line was "The Jews are our misfortune."
有一天，他说他找到了一个叫Julius Streicher的高级纳粹。Streicher是希特勒的朋友。他策划了一些最恶心的反犹太宣传。他的报纸《Der Stürmer》在助长导致大屠杀的对犹太人的仇恨方面发挥了巨大作用。报纸的标签是“犹太人是我们的不幸”。
So he was a man that Germans, especially German Jews, were familiar with. So when Werner found him--
所以他是一个德国人，尤其是德国犹太人熟悉的人。所以当Werner找到他时——
I was enraged. I was trembling. There were tears in my eyes that I had captured this guy. I had him to myself. Then I had him handcuffed, put him in the Jeep. And then we come to this little hut. Then we put him in there.
我被激怒了。我一直在颤抖。我眼里含着泪水，因为我抓住了这个家伙。我独自拥有了他。然后我给他戴上手铐，把他放进吉普车。然后我们来到这个小屋。然后我们把他放进去。
Werner's mother and sister were killed in concentration camps. He'd spent three months in Buchenwald himself in 1938. So face to face with Streicher, he made a decision. A warning to listeners, the next part gets a little graphic.
Werner的母亲和姐妹被杀害在集中营里。他自己1938年在布痕瓦尔德待了三个月。所以面对Streicher，他做了一个决定。提醒听众，下一部分有点血腥。
I had to explain to the MPs. I'm going to do things, you probably think I'm crazy. And you want to know something? I am crazy. I'm crazed. I captured a Nazi of unbelievable mischief. I captured a Nazi who doesn't deserve to live. I would like to shoot him right now, but I know I would be court marshaled. But I gonna, I'm gonna do what I have to do.
我不得不向军事警察解释。我要做一些事，你们可能认为我疯了。你想知道一些事吗？我是疯了。我疯了。我抓了一个不可思议的纳粹恶棍。我抓了一个不配活下去的纳粹。我真想现在就枪毙他，但我知道我会被送上军事法庭。但我会，我会做我必须做的事。
I had him undress, and his clothes throwed to the side, underwear, everything. I told him, from now on, you sleep naked on this cold floor. You will not move. You will not make a move.
我让他脱掉衣服，把衣服扔到一边，内衣，一切。我告诉他，从现在起，你赤身裸体睡在这个冰冷的地板上。你不能动。你不能动。
After that, I pissed all over him. Terrible thing to tell  you. His head and everywhere. And he started to move his head and I said to him, don't move. I have my pistol in my hand, I'll shoot you in  the ass. That's how enraged I was.
在那之后，我在他身上撒了尿。告诉你这是一件可怕的事。他的头和到处都是。他开始移动他的头，我对他说，别动。我手里拿着手枪，我会打爆你的屁股。我当时就是这么愤怒。
I said, you're just to lie there to get some sense of what you Nazis did to the Jews. This is only a small sense. You will not be burned here. We won't cook you  in an oven. But this German Jew will heap upon you. And don't you move, or else you're a dead man.
我说，你就躺在那里感受一下你们纳粹对犹太人做了什么。这只是一点点感受。你不会在这里被烧。我们不会把你放在烤箱里煮。但这名德国犹太人会堆积在你身上。别动，否则你就是个死人。
And I left into my quarters and went to sleep. It's a terrible thing to tell you, but it is the truth. That's what I did. This was an event that gets me very upset, even now.
然后我离开了我的宿舍去睡觉。告诉你这是一件可怕的事，但这是事实。这就是我做的。这是一个让我非常不安的事件，即使现在也是如此。
For three more days he held Streicher, refused to feed him anything but potato peels that he pissed on too. On the fourth day, Werner handed him off to American officers. Streicher was one of only 11 men sentenced to death at the Nuremberg trials.
他把Streicher关了三天，拒绝给他任何食物，除了他也撒了尿的土豆皮。第四天，Werner把他交给了美国军官。Streicher是纽伦堡审判中仅有的11名被判处死刑的人之一。
The specific records about Streicher's capture are spotty and contradictory. Usually someone else is credited with capturing him. But we know Werner was in the area doing this kind of work at the time. And an expert at the National Archives told me he does think Werner could have done this.
关于Streicher捕获的具体记录是零碎且矛盾的。通常其他人被认为抓获了他。但我们知道Werner当时正在该地区做这类工作。国家档案馆的一位专家告诉我，他确实认为Werner可能做到了这一点。
The man who helped me understand best what it was like to do this work was this last man, also Jewish. He escaped Luxembourg and came here.
帮助我最好地理解做这份工作是什么感觉的男人是最后这个人，也是犹太人。他逃离了卢森堡来到这里。
Well my name is Arno Mayer. And I don't want you to be generous, because it's A-R-N-O, and most people tend to add an L-D to it, which I refuse.
好吧，我的名字是Arno Mayer。我不希望你大方，因为它是A-R-N-O，大多数人倾向于在它后面加一个L-D，我拒绝了。
I met Arno at his apartment in Princeton, New Jersey. He was 88. Small guy, with a full head of white hair, brown eyebrows. He peppered our interview with historical facts and profanity.
我在新泽西州普林斯顿的公寓里见到了Arno。他88岁。小个子，满头白发，棕色眉毛。他在采访中夹杂着历史事实和脏话。
They invented a name for me. The name was the Intellectual Fuck.
他们为我发明了一个名字。名字叫“知识分子混蛋”。
Arno was assigned to PO Box 1142 at the end of the war. By then, the mission had changed. Instead of interrogating Nazis, they were now asked to wine, dine, and woo them.
Arno在战争结束时被分配到PO Box 1142。到那时，任务已经改变了。不是审问纳粹，他们现在被要求用酒、晚餐和求爱来对付他们。
Many Nazis now at the camp were scientists. They were rounded up because the Americans wanted their scientific expertise. And they wanted to keep that expertise from the Russians.
营地里的许多纳粹现在是科学家。他们被围捕是因为美国人想要他们的科学专长。他们想让那种专长远离俄国人。
Arno was what they called a morale officer.
Arno是他们所谓的士气官。
So what were your instructions with these guys?
那么你对这些家伙的指示是什么？
Keep them happy.
让他们快乐。
Make the Nazis happy. Not defeat them, not get information out of them. Charm them, get them to join our team.
让纳粹快乐。不是打败他们，不是从他们那里获取信息。吸引他们，让他们加入我们的团队。
It didn't make any sense. The whole thing didn't make any sense. I mean, the whole thing was so completely surreal, completely surreal.
这根本说不通。整件事根本说不通。我是说，整件事太超现实了，完全超现实。
Arno was assigned to the most famous Nazi recruit, Wernher von Braun. He designed the V-2 rocket which was targeted at civilians in London. His rocket factory used Jewish slaves. But Arno says they never discussed that. Instead, he and the others entertained the scientists. Some played games with them like volleyball or chess, or brought them liquor and newspapers, took them on outings to DC. Like a concierge, but for Nazis.
Arno被指派给最著名的纳粹新兵，Wernher von Braun。他设计了针对伦敦平民的V-2火箭。他的火箭工厂使用了犹太奴隶。但Arno说他们从未讨论过那个。相反，他和其他人娱乐那些科学家。有些人通过玩像排球或象棋这样的游戏来娱乐他们，或者给他们带来酒和报纸，带他们去华盛顿DC郊游。就像礼宾部，但却是为纳粹服务的。
The scientists told Arno about their wives and their kids, their lives. And after all that, he said it was hard to see the Nazis as just monsters.
那些科学家告诉Arno关于他们的妻子和孩子，他们的生活。经过这一切，他说很难把纳粹仅仅视为怪物。
I don't know. I mean, you can't just then proceed on the assumption well, these are subhumans and to hell with them. And the next time you bring a bottle of wine you put poison in it, you know.
我不知道。我是说，你不能仅仅基于那种假设，好吧，这些是次人类，去死吧，然后接着做。下次你带一瓶酒时，你在里面下毒，你知道。
Really?
真的吗？
I don't know. I don't know. It's a difficult question.
我不知道。我不知道。这是一个困难的问题。
Over time, the indignities of the job piled up. Until a small comment from von Braun set Arno off.
随着时间的推移，工作的屈辱堆积起来。直到von Braun的一句小评论让Arno爆发。
And he had already spoken behind my back of me as [GERMAN], a little Jew boy. So I lost it. And I stomped out. I was pretty shaken. Went back to my barrack and I'm summoned to the commander of the camp. Somebody had told him what I had said.
他已经在我背后称我为[德语]，一个小犹太男孩。所以我失去了控制。我气冲冲地走了。我非常震惊。回到我的营房，我被传唤到营地指挥官那里。有人告诉了他我说了什么。
And finally he said, if  you do this again you'll be court-martialed. That was for me one of the turning points, really.
最后他说，如果你再这样做，你就会被送上军事法庭。对我来说，那是转折点之一，真的。
After that, Arno became quietly subversive. Like when they asked to go shopping, Arno, for his own amusement, took them to a Jewish department store.
在那之后，Arno变得安静地颠覆。就像当他们要求购物时，Arno为了他自己的乐趣，把他们带到了一家犹太百货公司。
So he came and he said look, I'd like to send packages to our families in Germany, because it's going to be a rough winter. We'd like to go shopping. I was told, make them happy. So what the hell.
所以他来了，他说看，我想寄包裹给我们在德国的家人，因为那将是一个严酷的冬天。我们想去购物。我被告知，让他们快乐。所以管他呢。
And I began to be amused by this and decided that I was going to take them to the biggest Jewish department store in Washington, DC. So in    the car I asked them, what do we start with? Well, we want to buy underwear for our wives.
我开始觉得这很有趣，并决定把他们带到华盛顿DC最大的犹太百货公司。在车里我问他们，我们从什么开始？好吧，我们想给我们的妻子买内衣。
In those days, they didn't have bins in which this stuff was in. There was a sales lady. So the four of them, since they were scientists, you had these slide rules. They took them out as the woman asked what size, you see. So the woman came out and she held up a nylon panty. And Wernher von Braun said [GERMAN] but no, made of wool and with long legs.
在那些日子里，他们没有装这些东西的箱子。有一个女售货员。所以他们四个，因为他们是科学家，你有这些计算尺。当女人问尺码时，他们把它们拿出来了，你明白吗。所以女人出来了，她举起一条尼龙内裤。Wernher von Braun说[德语]，但不是，它是羊毛做的，有长腿。
In the meantime, people started looking around. There with these guys in these leather coats, and then there was this little guy next to them in an American uniform. And just as they were telling the lady about the sizes, the military police came and arrested the whole bunch of us.
与此同时，人们开始四处张望。那里有这些穿着皮大衣的家伙，然后旁边有这个穿着美国军装的小个子男人。就在他们告诉女人关于尺码的时候，宪兵来了，把我们一帮人都抓了。
[CHUCKLING]
[笑声]
They were conspicuous, this group of German-looking men making a ruckus. Arno told the police he was on a secret military mission. They verified it and let him go. But Arno says he knows his rebellion was small. And his restraint still haunts him.
他们很显眼，这群德国长相的男人制造了骚动。Arno告诉警察他是在执行秘密军事任务。他们验证了它并让他走了。但Arno说他知道他的叛乱很小。而他的克制仍然困扰着他。
I should have told them to go to hell. But I didn't do it. I was a coward. I mean, I only exploded once. I could have exploded many other times.
我本应该告诉他们去见鬼去吧。但我没做。我是个懦夫。我是说，我只爆发过一次。我本可以爆发更多次的。
Do you wish you had?
你希望你曾经爆发过吗？
Yeah, you're god damn right, god damn right, as I look back.
是啊，该死的你是对的，该死的你是对的，当我回头看时。
Wernher von Braun stayed in the United States and became something of an American hero. He helped us get to the moon. He was on the cover of Time. He became buddies with JFK.
Wernher von Braun留在了美国，成为了某种美国英雄。他帮助我们登上了月球。他登上了《时代》周刊的封面。他成了JFK的哥们。
And PO Box 1142 closed down. Its buildings were bulldozed. The files were burned. And the men who worked there went on to become lawyers, a CIA agent, an ambassador, head of the Culinary Institute of America, conductor of the Chicago Chamber Orchestra, the richest man in America in the '80s, John Kluge.
PO Box 1142关闭了。它的建筑物被推土机推平了。文件被烧毁了。在那里工作的人后来成了律师、CIA特工、大使、美国烹饪学院院长、芝加哥室内乐团指挥、80年代美国首富John Kluge。
Arno became a history professor at Princeton. And the guy who lost it and pissed on the Nazi started his own textile business. And all these men whose job it had been to extract secrets now carried their own. Most never said a word to their wives or kids about the work they had done, about the intimate war they had fought with the Germans in a park in Virginia.
Arno成了普林斯顿的历史教授。而那个失去控制并在纳粹身上撒尿的家伙创办了自己的纺织公司。所有这些曾经的工作是提取秘密的男人现在背负着他们自己的秘密。大多数人从未对他们的妻子或孩子说一句话关于他们做过的工作，关于他们在弗吉尼亚州公园与德国人进行的亲密战争。
Karen Duffin is one of the producers of our program.
Karen Duffin是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "WERNHER VON BRAUN" BY TOM LEHRER]
[音乐 - "WERNHER VON BRAUN" BY TOM LEHRER]
(SINGING) Gather 'round while I sing you of Wernher von Braun, a man whose allegiance is ruled by expedience. Call him a Nazi, he won't even for frown, Nazi, schmatzy, says Wernher von Braun.
(演唱) 聚在一起，当我要为你唱关于Wernher von Braun，一个忠诚被权宜之计统治的人。叫他纳粹，他甚至不会皱眉，纳粹，没关系，Wernher von Braun说。
Don't say that he's hypocritical. Say rather that he's apolitical. Once the rockets are up, who cares where they come down. That's not my department, says Wernher von Braun.
不要说他是虚伪的。倒不如说他是非政治的。火箭升空后，谁在乎它们会落到哪里。那不是我的部门，Wernher von Braun说。
Some have harsh words for this man of renown. But some think our attitude should be one of gratitude. Like the widows and cripples in old London town, who owe their large pensions to Werner von Braun.
有些人对这个有名的人有刻薄的评论。但有些人认为我们的态度应该是感恩。就像伦敦老城的寡妇和残疾人，他们欠Wernher von Braun的高额养老金。
You too may be a hero once you've learned to count backwards to zero. In German or English I know how to count down. And I'm learning Chinese says Wernher von Braun.
你也可以成为英雄，一旦你学会从零开始倒数。用德语或英语我知道怎么倒数。而且我正在学习中文，Wernher von Braun说。
Our program is produced today by Susan Burton and David Kestenbaum. Our Production staff, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvas, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Ship, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike.
我们的节目今天由Susan Burton和David Kestenbaum制作。我们的制作人员，Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvas, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Ship, Matt Tierney, 和 Nancy Updike。
Our editor is Joel Lovell. Editing help from Julie Snyder and Elna Baker.
我们的编辑是Joel Lovell。Julie Snyder和Elna Baker提供编辑帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
At our website this week we have all kinds of stuff. The fax that Jack Bailey received assigning him to represent Trastavien Hardy that we've annotated with all kinds of revealing information. Also pictures and documents about PO Box 1142, including stuff on their interrogation techniques. And something called-- no kidding-- the POW Coddling Report. That's at our website, ThisAmericanLife.org where you can also sign up for our weekly newsletter.
本周在我们的网站上有各种各样的东西。Jack Bailey收到的指派他代表Trastavien Hardy的传真，我们标注了各种揭示信息。还有关于PO Box 1142的照片和文件，包括关于他们审问技术的东西。还有一些叫作——没开玩笑——“战俘溺爱报告”的东西。那在我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org，你也可以在那里订阅我们的每周通讯。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心交付给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia who, ever since we've met, he's had this affectionate nickname I've always liked that he's always liked to call me--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生，他自我们见面以来，一直有一个我一直很喜欢的昵称，他一直喜欢称呼我——
[GERMAN], a little Jew boy.
[德语]，一个小犹太男孩。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。